hi everybody I'd like to start off by
thanking my mom for throwing a bunch of
granola bars in my bag this week we
really needed them and it was a busy
week and thank you so much the Academy
for letting us all be a part of it the
fact that so many resources are put into
giving us the best opportunity we can
have it having a career in filmmaking is
truly astounding thank you so much to
Shawn in your whole team there's
something about going to see a movie
that has always stuck with me and the
fact that you get to go in a room like
this but smaller and not so many toggled
men and the curtains open and the lights
go down and you're surrounded by
strangers but you aren't alone and
whether you have a story that's worth
telling or you want to entertain or you
want to connect with people you're
you're providing that experience of not
being alone for two hours to strangers
so I'm truly honored to accept this and
get to tell stories and provide that for
other people I'd like to thank my family
all over there all the Malloys and my
parents Nancy and Kevin my grandparents
Tom and Sharon for always supporting me
in my entire cast and crew I'd like to
end by thanking my two women who this
film could not have been made without
and who were unbelievably supportive of
me and that's my lead actress Lizzie
Clark and my producer Sarah Holzman
I I may have been the captain of this
ship but you two ladies built the ship
for me to captain so thank you so much
and thanks to my mentors at Chapman
thank you I'm very honored thanks
[Applause]